wade leblanc who spent some time with
baltimore and in the minors with the
texas rangers this year but he is going
to start for the st louis cardinals
tonight and now christian walker
3-2 pitch
and little choppery at left side arenado
cuts it off spins throws oh what a play
nolan aronado
to get christian walker jake farrell is
going to make his first start in the
d-max uniform he made seven of them for
the angels top affiliate and aaa before
the d-backs purchased his contract
here's aronado
the cardinals on base percentage to 298
is dead last in the national league and
only cleveland and seattle have a lower
on base percentage in baseball not even
300
for the st louis cardinals
the 3-2 breaking ball and he got him
looking what a beauty and a nice crisp
one two three inning for jake faria
cardinals down in order we go to the top
of the second no score in st louis fish
paving smith the diamondbacks right
fielder and the one-two delivery by
david smith is a fly ball deep into
right field and it's a
nice play by the cardinal right killer
and nukesville he goes back leaps and
mix the catch
dalton bar show their catcher ahmed is
at the shortstop and he's at third base
here's a ground ball to the
second baseman with the shift on he's
out at first base and then
254 average with seven overs and 31
driven in
maria spent all of last year at the
brewers alternate side in appleton
wisconsin
so he did not appear in the major
leagues last year he said it was tough
being at the old site all year not
getting an opportunity
got released by milwaukee in november
signed that minor league deal with the
angels and now
here he is with the diamondbacks
got molina to chase second strikeout for
jake faria two outs in the second a
runner in scoring position for dylan
carlson
the 1-1
carl's head
into right make it down it does
bare into the corner one run is in
carlson racing to third standing up with
a triple
zosis scores
one nothing saint louis and the batter
is paul goldsmith
the diamondbacks bringing the infield in
here in this third inning
here's the 3-2 from jake ferrier
fastball he struck him out
challenged him with a fastball very
hittable pitch at 92 but goldie swung
through it strikes out for round number
two and that's the third strikeout for
jake faria and now nolan arenado who
took a call third strike his first time
up
another fastball away drives it to right
pavement is there
but the cardinals break on top
i get by sosa leblanc the pitcher butted
him up carlson tripled him home he was
left at third as goldschmidt strikeout
or not will fly to right we go to the
top of the fourth one of the cardinals
it's juvenile ground to the third his
first time up
here's the pitch and that's down to
third fair ball
oh oh oh
the uh whatever they call him they don't
call him a golden glover
but he's going to cross the cardinals
there dieback's going to have runners at
second and third
as the
man patrolling
the
warning track area there and foul
territory thought that ball i guess was
fouled and he fielded it
so the bases will be loaded
martial grounded out with a runner in
third and two outs back in the second
the pitch
swing and a miss varshall strikes out
yachty dropped the ball picks it up
steps on the plate
there's the first strikeout for the
block and now edmundo
who had to hit his first time up and
score the only run of this game
the angels at yankee stadium went top
four to three seventh inning
with another home run from ohtani fly
ball center field
back on the la cash show near the
warning track makes a catch
and that will retire sosa and then the
cardinal fourth inning they get to hit
in the end there was a hit banner in the
ending two men left on base we go to the
top of the fifth in st louis here is
joshua van meter
fifth inning for wade leblanc four
scoreless so far
65 pitches and counting for wayne
leblanc one strikeout one walk that was
intentional and that has been it three
hits no runs
and the o2
struck him out on the outside corner
ross third time he's looked at
the left heela block now he's over two
he's fly to left ground to short
and a fly ball hit to center hit pretty
well to center back of the warning track
at the wall touch them all josh rojas
a home run to tie the ball game of one
josh's tenth of the year hit it out to
center
you could tell that he was a little
upset with his first two at bats
and this time what he made the most out
of it he drove that ball a long ways
carlson just kept going back and finally
stopped running
he ran out of room 1-1 ball game
they have pulled back peralta
and the pitcher young
will hit
left-handed better fishing uh camaro
fastball is strike three tall
he didn't even swing the bat here comes
tyler o'neil o'neal has a hit tonight
one for two their left fielder young
looks back at arenado the base runner
the pitch and it's popped up
playable
pavon smith coming on in right field
and makes the catch falls down arnado
bluffs going to third base
but he hangs on there and payment gets
the ball back in i think he ended up
catching that ball in fair territory
didn't he he did
so one out a big out there without the
runner moving off sink of the batteries
molina molina's over two but here
especially against the diamondbacks it
seems in his careers where he's really
been good
three one count on yadi or molina young
looks back at oronato and brings it home
and molina hits one to short diving play
by ahmed gets up and throws him out at
first
nice play by nick took ahead and an rbi
away from molina with a diving stop at
short
newt barr tonight has fly to center line
to left
now facing the left-hander alex young
two out of two out arenado de young the
base runners
the other runners will take off
there they go here it is got him
swinging the endings over
big strikeout for alex shot
walker advances to the right-handed
batters box it's right-hander facing
right-hander now
one ball and one strike to christian
walker
lined into left o'neal diving and he
came up with it he robbed him
takes a hit away
here's dylan carlson carlson has the
cardinal rbi tonight
carlson base headed to center on the 1-2
pitch
and the cardinals have the lead dylan
has brought in two tonight 2-1 st louis
carlson on for goldschmidt goldie is
sitting on 11
home runs
[Applause]
ground ball up the middle
that's a base hit
carlson will score
it's a 3-1 save lewis lead
gold smith drives in his 41st 3-1
cardinals o'neal is at first goldsmith
at second for yatiere molina
molina pulls it fair
off the sidewall one run is in here
comes another
yachty on his way to second base with a
double
[Applause]
395 doubles for his career and with that
he passes jason kendall
sole possession sixth all-time in major
league history among primary catchers in
doubles
and here's paul deyoung with a runner at
second and two gone and the cardinals
have a four-run seventh inning going and
the 1-0 pitch
de young with a drive
left center
two-run homer paul the young and the
cardinals have busted it wide open here
in the home half of the seventh
now carlson bets
94 knocked down by walker de gus gets
over there and he works another one two
three eighth inning david peralta with
the diamondbacks down to their last out
the pitch to him a swing and a drive to
right field tommy edmond moves back he
makes the catch for a red bird winner